[Music]
when i was
younger my grandmother when i would you
know like come down into the kitchen in
the morning she would always say ah now
the sun has risen for me which was
always such a nice thing to hear
i've constantly striven to try to make
my father proud
and uh one moment was after uh a
performance with the san diego symphony
he said uh i'm proud of you and i was
really that hit hard
so i heard this recently um and it's
being heartbroken or being in pain
doesn't make you
a less complete person and makes you
more whole like a more
you've lived more life and you have more
experiences and that was just like
[Music]
well um you know when when i get asked
is that like the first thing that
crossed my mind was my mother telling me
meaning also meaning your muscle is my
beautiful key that would be like the
translation
i guess would be my beautiful boy that
would be better than my beautiful kid
yeah when she say it they just smell my
heart you know
when those words come to my mind like
it's just like a flashback of all
those nice moments with her you know
like i can remember twisting and she
will pass the hand on my
uh like here until i fall asleep that
would be like
you know like just blow my mind you know
just to remember the things and
i just don't want to cry in front of the
camera but you know that's what it
just you know it flashed my brain i
guess
there was this old person at a senior
home that i worked at and he had
alzheimer's
and he said that i was the kind of
person that he would never forget i
didn't feel very good i was like oh i've
never heard that before i've never heard
that from
somebody especially that has alzheimer's
i didn't expect it
the most beautiful thing that i've been
told is that i'm cancer free
i've been diagnosed with cancer three
times and the three times i've been
blessed enough to
get out of it cancer-free
[Music]
uh the most beautiful thing that i've
ever been told is probably that i have a
good vocabulary
i've gotten told it by like one of my
best friends maybe like four years ago
and i bring it up all the time i'm like
you know you told me that i have a
really good vocabulary once and
that like resonated with me i love that
why do you think it resonated with you
i think it's just so different than like
the regular compliment that you would
get like oh you look pretty or
like you know you have a nice smile like
i think
someone telling you like intellectually
that you have a good vocabulary it's
just a really great compliment
i like the way you look at people
because it makes them feel seen do you
remember who said it to you
one of my students one of my eighth
graders was there more context to that
like with that specific student like why
they would say that
i think because he's a trans boy
and it was a catholic school and like
nobody really accepted him
except for like me so i was always like
respectful of his pronouns and stuff
like that and
i guess i just made him feel like he
mattered i shared my experience that i
used to have depression and anxiety
and one of my co-workers was like how
like you're always smiling and laughing
and you're like you're bright in the
room and i'm like well you know like
sometimes
people that you know have dealt with
things
are the people that smile and laugh the
most so i think that when she told me
that i felt like it was special because
i do
had a lot my you know my pain with
making other people laugh and smile
so i felt it was beautiful for her to
say that
okay so to give some context i'm going
through my first breakup right now
um and it's been really hard but i was
talking to
one of my friends and she had told me
that you know it's always
like i was just questioning so many
things i was like was it even worth it
to care about someone this much and
she told me that you know like love is
always
worth it even when it's hard and just
because
it didn't work out this time doesn't
mean it won't work out next time and
it's always good to
open your heart to love and let that in
and allow yourself
to be cared for by someone else and that
was really meaningful to me and i think
that's the most beautiful thing i've
heard recently
my dad is always like you're my little
angel and
um he always says that he always he
looked up at the sky full of stars and
he picked one out and it became me
most beautiful thing that i've been told
is that i am a wholesome person
i want to tell i'm a great person
when a stranger told me i had a nice
smile because i'm really insecure about
my teeth
you do have a nice smile thank you
um that i was pretty and i was like you
know what you're absolutely correct
thank you for reaffirming and confirming
that's what it is
to be honest i am a little bit of a
loner i
spend half of my life at sea on a ship
so a lot of the things that i see
are more beautiful and stand out to me
than something that anyone can tell me
verbally
i haven't really interact with people
probably as much as anyone else
around here in this balboa park so
usually it's things that i see visually
that resonate with me the most
what's one of the most beautiful things
that you've seen
probably a beautiful reef
that i served in the maldives and it was
intact there was no trash
there was abundance of fish and sea life
and
it was all harmonious and it was just
really nice to see that because
the reefs are going and the human impact
on the planet is kind of crazy so to see
something left intact
and everyone enjoying it and leaving it
alone the way it's supposed to be it was
really
really pretty okay i was a city planner
in the toledo ohio i
proposed a landscape ordinance for the
city
i found out the mayor of the city was
stabbing us in the back
i was in the public hearing room and and
the entire government center hears the
planned commission hearings
and i said if the i know the mayor's
listening and i want him to stay out of
our process
and i really laid it into him and when i
shut the books and i
got up from the desk in front of all the
lights i thought my career was over
i took the elevator to the 16th floor i
walk in
it's a line of cubicles and like a corny
movie
the planters came out of the cubicles
applauding me as i walked by and i
that was to be appreciated for my honest
efforts
to defend the process a legitimate
process
was my greatest compliment my greatest
that's the nicest thing i've ever been
told
is that i in had integrity and i put it
all on the line
after i gave birth the doctor and nurses
said my body was made to birth babies
and why was that beautiful to you it
made me feel strong and tough
after a natural delivery someone told me
that they
that i inspire them to be more more
genuine and like
selfless which i think is really nice um
it was one of my co-workers and we're
hostesses so it's like nothing big but
she says that
i inspire her to be like more open and
like
talkative and like come out of her shell
because i inspired her to be that way
so i have a friend as a musician so i
was talking to him
and he has a new record that he was
coming out with and i was just like oh
that's crazy i do like his music and i'm
like what's the name of the record gonna
be
he's like well i haven't told me too
many people but it's actually gonna be
called no more beautiful world
and i had this real moment of like oh
man that's kind of dour
like you know no more beautiful world he
goes well that's how you interpret it
he's like what else could it be and
i'm like what do you mean he's like well
it could be there's no more beautiful
world
and it was a really important moment in
my life of sort of the like
the black and white nature things the
two sides of the same coin of like how
you choose to look at something matters
right it's like you can choose the
negative path or you can choose the
positive path
and with my i have three girls and i
tell all of them all the time of like
when
you ten i've noticed especially with my
teenage daughter can you can really tend
to go to dark places and certain things
and when i always refresh her memory of
hey no more beautiful world i can be
what you want it to be you can choose
the positive side of thing if you want
to choose that side of things
so i thought always think of that story
as one of the more beautiful things that
was ever told to me
i think the most beautiful thing i've
been told is that
life actually is meaningless so the
meaning isn't what you make it
and that means when people are sad there
really is no meaning behind life so they
can realize i don't have to be sad
i can choose not to be because
ultimately i'm in control of what i want
to do and how to feel
because if life is meaningless then i'm
all the meaning i can give it
i was told that i'm an angel i was
strung out on heroin i was
in jail for committing crimes and i was
40 years old by the way
first sober man i ever met said to me
that i had a choice
in life and i didn't even understand
what that meant that i had choices
right so my choices were that i i could
go
to prison and stay sober if i were to be
in prison
or if i had the opportunity to get it
back out into the world
i could do that as a as a sober person
as well
and and that was that statement that i'm
an angel right and so today
what i've realized is the result of that
12 years later as a recovering drug
addict
is that we all do have choices every
single solitary day we make choices
upon waking up and and that's the
beautiful thing about
being a human on this planet is we have
a choice
you know and i'm grateful today i'm
grateful that i know that i have a
choice
every single solitary day whether i make
the wrong choice
or or the right choice right is that i
have this opportunity
to make a choice so i was debating
becoming a firefighter
six years ago and my father was really
influential in that decision because
he's like
you've always done your own thing gone
your own path
and i have learned as much from you as
you've learned from me being your dad
so i think you can do it you can handle
it so
six years in this is good advice i feel
like parents can be very
difficult uh relationships and you don't
always say things and you typically
don't ever say what you actually mean
and i think growing up my relationship
with my dad was not very
like give and take and loving so just
hearing something like really soft and
sweet from him was like
wow i want to cry um the most beautiful
thing i've been told is probably
someone random saying they're proud of
me when i graduated and
saying that i earned what i
i don't know but it's just better like
from a stranger than
from someone i know you know okay yeah
cool i'm
i'm curious why that is like someone
close to you said that like it wouldn't
mean as much you think
my family don't really talk to me so i'm
good oh i see
okay so like just the fact that even
someone said it okay cool thank you for
sharing
good job hey guys
thanks for watching remember that i have
a new channel for my podcast so if
you've been wondering where the new
episodes are for that
make sure to check that out it's linked
in the description i love you all
and i'll see you next week